drifting in the seagrass of dorset
studland bay a spiny seahorse the
coronavirus lockdown has meant
boats haven't been able to anchor in
their breeding ground this spring
and they've thrived it's an example of
how eliminating destructive human impact
allows marine life to quickly bounce
back a new report
commissioned by the government calls for
at least five
highly protected marine areas to be set
up around the english coast
that would ban fishing dredging and
other damaging activity
the author a former fisheries minister
told me
the zones would be good for conservation
and those who rely on the sea for income
the fishing industry if it's done right
can benefit from
the large amount of fish and shellfish
in particular
that spill out into the neighboring
areas of water and can be
sustainably exploited and so
there is a a sweet spot if we can get it
right
where everybody benefits
sky ocean rescue has campaigned for
improved marine protection
we followed un patron of the oceans
louis pugh's
swim along the length of the english
channel as he highlighted the threat of
climate change plastic pollution
and overfishing to the ecosystem he's
disappointed the government
isn't acting faster my message to the
united kingdom government is please
stop dipping your toes in the water dive
in
with enthusiasm these things work our
children need them
our incredible wildlife needs them our
tourism industry needs it
the government has committed to meeting
the united nations target of protecting
30 of the ocean by 2030 and has what it
calls a blue
belt of marine protected areas around
the coast
but conservation groups say they fall
well short of what marine life
needs to thrive and urge the government
to bring in protection
worthy of the name thomas more sky news